the other thing that i
love talking about is the different time
scales at which things happen
you know we're talking about the
humanity genome before the human
epigenome is basically able to find
what genes should be expressed in
response to environmental stimuli
in the order of minutes and basically
receive a stimulus
transfer all that data through this
humongously long string
of searching and then sort of find what
genes to turn
on and then create all that all of that
is happening in the time scale of
minutes basically you know three minutes
to a to half an hour
that's the expression response but our
daily life doesn't happen on the order
of three minutes to
half an hour it happens on the order of
milliseconds like i throw a ball at you
you catch it right away
no gene expression changes there you
just don't have time to do that
so you basically have a layer of control
built on a hardware that supports it
but that hardware itself lives in a
different time scale
than the controlling machine on top of
that is that an accident by the way is
that like a feature
is it was it possible for life to have
evolved where
the our d the daily life of the organism
as it interacts with its environment
was on time scale similar to uh the
the way our internals work if you look
at
trees they look kind of boring and
stupid you're like looking at a tree
like stupid
if you speed up the movie of a tree from
spring
until october you'll be like oh my god
it's intelligent
and the reason for that is that at that
time scale
the tree is basically saying oh i'm
looking for a you know a
thing to catch on to oh i just caught on
to that i'm going to grow more here i'm
going to spawn there etc
like i can see the trees in my garden
just growing and sort of you know
looping around and
it's all a matter of time scale and if
you look at the human time scale
remember we were talking about neotimi
the last time around the whole fact that
our young are pretty useless until
you know maybe you know a few months of
age if not a few years of age
if not i don't know getting out of
college and then
we we basically hold them enabling their
brain
to continue being malleable and infusing
it with knowledge and
you know thoughts as you know that
period of neotimi
increases and expands if you fast
forward
i don't know another million years so
humans have only been around
you know different from apes for about
that long
jump another unit of that another human
gym divergence
what could happen from an evolutionary
time scale a lot one of the things
that's happening already
is expansion of human lifespan we have
longer and longer periods before we
mature
and we have longer and longer periods
because before we have babies
so intergenerational distance is you
know grown from i don't know 16 years to
40 years you're saying that's in the
genetics
like no no not necessarily but but it's
it's sort of an environmental tendency
that's happening
but as we medically expand
human lifespan the
generations might actually be pushed
instead of 40 years
to 60 years to 100 years if we look at
the long arc
of the evolutionary history exactly so
as we start thinking about intergalactic
travel now
sorry that's that's a heck of a
transition
uh yeah so let's talk about it no no no
no as as we
as a species start thinking about i mean
i'm talking about these transitions that
are happening right now and that's
that's
so awesome continuing along these
transitions what does the future hold
in the next million years so the concept
of us going to another planet
and that taking three human lifetimes
might be a joke
if the human lifetime starts being 400
years or
800 years so imagine
this time scale it's all time scale just
different time skills
you asked me offline whether i would
like to live forever i mean
my answer is absolutely
and there's many different types of
forevers one forever
is do i want to live today
forever kind of like groundhog day and
the answer is
absolutely the stuff that i want to
learn today will probably take a
lifetime
just to learn you know basically to
clear my to-do list for the day
you mean like relive the day of the day
and then and then pick up different
things from the richness of the
experiences
there's just so much happening in the
world every single day so much knowledge
that has happened already
that just to catch up on that will
probably take me around forever
and that on that point i just i would
just love to see you in the groundhog
movie
just because you're so
naturally as a scientist but just the
way your mind works beautifully
just all the richness of the experiences
that you would pick up from that
uh that's a beautiful visual but you try
to live each day as if it was groundhog
i'm basically every single day waking up
and saying all right how would bill
murray
get out of that one well you know what
on uh
on a funny tangent like i got a chance
to uh
go to a neural link demonstration event
i'm not usually familiar with your link
and uh i talked to elon for a while uh
and one of the funny things she said on
this grong hog
day thing is you know it's a beautiful
dream to
eventually be able to replay our
memories so we're
kind of these recording machines our
brain is kind of
uh maybe a noisy recording machine of
memories
and it'll be beautiful if we can
someday in the future maybe far into the
future
be able to like in the groundhog day
situation replay that
and the funny comment that stuck with me
is he said that
maybe this our conversation now is a
replay
of a member of a previous memory and
that stuck with me because
it would probably be my replay you know
who the hell am i i'm just some
idiot guy but like elon musk is you know
probably because of spacex and so on is
probably going to be remembered as a
special person
one of our special apes in history
so if i wanted to replay a memory
probably be that one you know talking to
elon for a while yeah
and that's the interesting uh
possibility from uh
if we think about time scales if we
think about
the richness of the experience through
time
that we humans take and be able to
replace some aspects of that of that
biology that's
super interesting but anyway sorry sorry
for the tangent let's
yeah you were talking about time scales
and the expansion of the
human lifetime and uh
intergalactic travel yeah no but but
you're laughing about this
yeah for sure that is you're talking
about this you're talking about
exploring alien worlds yeah and going to
other planets i mean
you know when sarah was here she was
talking about sort of going to other
planets
when we find this life i mean i'm just
very naturally
given the topics that we've approached
talking about the the time scale at
which this will happen
so i think eventually we will human or
life
life will expand out into the universe
the the point that i'm trying to make is
that in intergalactic species
we'll probably find ways to engineer its
biology
in order to expand the way that we
experience
time expand the the time skills that we
and going back to this whole concept of
you know would i like to live forever
yes i'd like to live forever even if it
was even if i was stuck on the same day
i'd love to live forever because i would
finally have time to do all these things
that i want to do
but if living forever actually comes
with a perk
of watching the whole world evolve
forever
i mean that's a huge perk and i would
you know just
it'll never get boring just an
ever-changing world
and then the mind uh you know sort of
experiment that i want you to to do is
to also ask
what if i wanted to live forever one day
at a time
every year or one day at a time every
decade
would you choose that where you would
wake up and the world would be 10 years
later
every single day you wake up it's the
opposite of groundhog day
where basically you always wake up and
it's always 10 years later
so you're saying that's such a powerful
interesting concept that life is
more interesting if you're of all the
life forms on earth
that you're the slowest one exactly
exactly like trees
have it right have it right olive trees
like you know they've been there since
the minoan civilization
you